i'm amazed by the number of people here
who are not disaffected republicans
but are coming which is obviously the
traditional route to libertarianism
you know you're a republican who really
believes it you wake up in mourning and
realize your party really doesn't
believe it
you look for someone who does and you
wind up with the libertarian side there
are a lot of people here who didn't go
that route
who came here from other ideological
places
yeah their answer were liberals there
are people who i mean
my experience is this you almost always
hear people say well it's not a question
of left versus right well actually it
almost always is a question of left
versus right i mean almost any
issue public policy issue does cleave
down left first traditional left versus
right
um lines this is the only place i've
ever been
where there really are people who can't
be explained by reference to left versus
right
they really are sort of from somewhere
else it's interesting
well because he's a threat of course i
mean he's look
i mean i think there are some
republicans who have principal
differences with ron paul who
who think his foreign policy is reckless
for instance or who think
the gold standard is impractical or
crackpot i mean and i i it's fair to
believe that as far as i'm concerned
i have questions about his foreign
policy and disagree with it
to some extent but at the
party leadership level they don't like
ron paul because he calls them out for
being the phonies they are
the appeal of ron paul there's like a
basic
contradiction that's central to his
appeal okay ron paul is appealing
because he refuses to lead
because he refuses to command he refuses
to tell other people what to do
it's not just ideological it's
temperamental like that's who he is as a
person and he can't help it
and so ron paul will never get up and
say you
do this you follow me he's just that's
not who he is and that's why people like
him
but because that's not who i mean you
have to be that guy in order to
organize an efficient movement yeah i
don't think of this in
normal political terms you know is this
a movement if so where does it go from
here
i think the whole purpose of it is to
inform
the rest of the country that there are
people who are committed to a
non-authoritarian non-dictatorial
worldview
and that they're not crazy or at least
not all of them are crazy
and um you know they're worth listening
to well they don't understand it at all
of course though i must say i think paul
is treated with
more affection than you would expect
mostly because i think most people
who cover politics don't have any idea
what he's really saying
or the implications of it for another
describing yourself as libertarian is
like an easy way not to be a republican
for a lot of people
because it's so embarrassing to say i'm
a republican who voted for bush
but you're kind of conservative so you
don't want to identify with the
democrats you say i'm a libertarian
you know it's a kind of port in a storm
for a lot of people and um
and an acceptance socially accepted
dodge
and and i think that's the way it's seen
in by a lot of people in the press so
it's like ron paul you know he's kind of
harmless seems like a nice guy
you know he's for smoking weed you know
i'm for him or i'm not against him i
don't think he's scary he's not
pat buchanan 92 or something you know
someone who's really reviled by
journalists by the lifestyle liberals
the know-nothings who run
america's networks
there's any
well i'm struck by this is not a
particularly resonant issue for me
though i'm not making fun of it but it
doesn't
move me to tears or laughter but the
federal reserve stuff
has remarkable resonance with other
people i mean it's unbelievable the
number of people
i've interviewed ron paul fans who say
you know it's the gold standard that got
me here
which is not something you would expect
when i did this story about ron paul for
the new republican that was
that was the number one most surprising
thing i learned
was the seriousness uh with which people
sort of
take the federal reserve i mean and they
should i'm not mocking it in any way i'm
just saying i didn't expect it
you know you would expect people to be
like well i want to smoke pot i'm
libertarian or
you know i've got an unusual sexual
proclivity i'm libertarian no it's these
are like people who
care about this very abstract pretty
complicated issue of monetary policy
i did i did actually look into it i did
and
i'm not sure i'm i'm a deep enough
person or have a solid enough grounding
in economics to fully appreciate it but
i certainly didn't dismiss it as crazy
at
it's it's all you're saying it's easy to
dodge to say i'm a libertarian more than
i'm a republican do you think
the whole campaign made it maybe easier
to say that
is the brand no i don't i think actually
ron paul challenged the republican party
pretty directly and pretty aggressively
and offended a lot of partisan
republicans good for him by the way
in my view but um no i think he
put a kind of harder edge on it
a more anti-republican edge on it i mean
when i was growing up the libertarians
at least in southern california where
i'm from
libertarians were kind of they were sort
of sympathetic to the republicans
kind of i mean the republican party was
different then too but
now i think there's more hostility i
have no clue i you know i sometimes
don't vote
um because i have my own set of crackpot
criteria for voting that i'm not going
to impose upon you by describing them
but i will
just say i mean i i've got my own
theories about it and so sometimes i
don't vote and no i don't feel bad about
voting and yes i still feel entitled to
complain even though i don't vote
for you understanding people say it's
correct they're gonna write ron paul's
name
absolutely i'm a big believer in um in
voting your conscience i think a vote is
an endorsement
i don't think it's going to be done
lightly i don't think you should vote
for things you sort of agree with
at least that's how i feel i mean i
don't judge other people's
criteria but mine is you know i feel
like a vote is a pretty significant
act and you know there are all kinds of
things i don't vote on i live in
washington dc and
there are all sorts of things i don't
understand or candidates that never
heard of i'm sure they're all awful
anyway
but i often don't vote there's a ton of
groups here you're here
paul gets away pretty easily with
getting all these weird like groups that
like
you said 96 would have been french
groups that make him scary right
in this big circus
well that's kind of the genius and the
pitfall the basic pitfall of what
ron paul has done i mean it's such a
loose
affiliation of groups you know it's sort
of anybody who
kind of wants to join can and that's a
great thing
but maybe in the long term not a great
organizing principle for a political
movement
you know i don't know i'm not a
political scientist but but his
temperament allows that
i mean i i remember you know saying when
i was riding around with him for the
story you know well gee i think that
sounds like a very bad idea
to something an opinion he offered and
he said well it's okay
not everyone has to agree i mean
whatever the
the opposite of a cult of personality is
that's what he seeks
to create it's like no you don't have to
sign up with everything i believe
i don't take it personally i like that
that's nice
no no no
look libertarianism in my view
cuts against human nature pretty
dramatically half of it is really
appealing the half that says i can do
pretty much whatever i want
but the other half that other people
ought to be allowed to do pretty much
whatever they want even if they're like
annoying to me and on the wrong course
as far as i'm concerned that's
deeply unappealing to people people
intrinsically want to control other
people's behavior
and they figure out all kinds of
justifications well i know what's best
oh no don't do that you'll get hurt
or i've done that before that's a bad
idea or
if you are only smart enough or as smart
as i am you would see this
whatever justification they offer they
have a natural desire almost all of them
to control other people and that's
you know contrary to the basic tenet of
libertarianism
so it's very easy for people so i'm a
libertarian yeah i think everyone should
do what he wants
meaning me
yeah no so i don't ever think i mean i'm
sorry i know that you all are a
libertarian organization i support
reason and i i
sincerely do i read it i'm a nick lesbi
fan i mean i've been like a lifelong
self-identified libertarian
i don't think that most people will ever
get there
ever ever sorry
you have two choices you can vote the
republican or the democrat let's be real
no one else is getting elected and you
know vote for the lesser of two evils i
mean that's a
i think that's an adult argument i don't
agree with it
but i think it's fair what do you think
sarah palin
sarah palin hunts and fishes
okay so as a sportsman i have
a profound emotional attachment to sarah
palin
that a reason doesn't touch
i mean in other words you could tell me
that sarah palin i don't know
had breakfast with satan last week at
the four seasons
and it wouldn't really damage my love
for her
because she caught a 30-pound sockeye
salmon herself
that's how i feel about it